What we just described is termed self serving bias. And a self serving bias is
when we have the tendency to make situational attributions for our failures,
and dispositional attributions for our successes. And the reason we asked you
to pay so close attention to this attribution theory is because of this self
serving bias. Now, when I first started teaching psychology and covered this
topic, I was actually quite surprised by how often I used dispositional
attributions to explain other people's behavior. And now that I'm aware of it,
I try to first look at perhaps situational attributions. For example, if my
friend doesn't call me back, I try to look at perhaps reasons such as her phone
is dead, or maybe she's on the phone with her boyfriend, or she had to work
late, instead of using a dispositional attribution and saying perhaps she's
lazy or selfish. Can you think of any times in your life when you've used a
situational attribution instead of a dispositional one, or vice versa?